[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: Hi, folks.
Welcome back.
So we will continue our
discussion that we had--
that we've been doing for
the past few lectures.
We first talked about
time complexity.
And then we shifted gears to
talk about space complexity.
So we had a couple of
lectures on PSPACE,
kind of culminating in proving
that there were languages which
are PSPACE complete,
namely this TQBF language,
which is where we started.
And then we also proved that
there are problems involving
games, such as the generalized
geography game, where
determining which side
has a winning strategy
is PSPACE complete.
At the end of the
lecture last time,
we moved to a different
regime of space,
namely from polynomial
space down to log space.
And we introduced
the classes L and NL.
And so I'm going to
begin today's lecture
by reviewing some of the
material on N and NL,
which I think came a little
too quickly last time.
And then we have two
important theorems
we're going to cover today.
One is about proving that there
are complete languages for NL
that has a bearing on the
L versus NL question--
log space,
deterministic log space,
versus nondeterministic
log space.
That's yet another unsolved
problem in our field.
And so there is a notion of
a complete problem for NL.
And then we're going
to prove a theorem that
was, in its day, very
surprising to people.
I remember when it
came out in the 1980s,
that NL, in fact, is closed
under complementation,
that the NL class and coNL
class both collapse to 1,
that they're equal, which
is not the way we believe
the situation to be for NP.
But until someone has a
proof that they're different,
strange things can happen.
OK.
So with that, I will move
myself into the corner.
And let's do our review.
So we are-- in order to talk
about space complexity classes
that are smaller than n, we
had to introduce a new model,
which was the two-tape model,
where there was a read-only
tape that had the input on it,
which you normally would think
of something very large--
the whole internet,
or something so big
that you can't read it
into your local memory.
And then you have a work tape,
which is your local memory.
And the way we're going to think
about it in the context of log
space is that that work tape
is logarithmic in the size
of the input.
And that is enough to have
small counters or pointers
into the input, because a
reference location of the input
is just--
you only need log
n bits to do that.
So we gave a couple of
examples of the L and NL--
of L and NL languages, so
this language of ww reverse,
as you may remember.
So here is an input
in ww reverse.
It's a string follow-- it's
a palindromic string, which
is of even length.
And so you can make a
machine in log space here
that can test whether its
input is of that form.
And the work tape is only--
all it needs is a
pointer into the--
or a couple of
pointers that refer
to the corresponding
places of the input
that you're looking
at at the moment.
So you maybe start
out looking at the two
outside a's and then the b
symbols that are next to that.
And you can write
down on your tape
where you're looking currently.
And so that's going
to be enough for you
to-- you may have to zigzag,
of course, back and forth a lot
in order to do that test.
But that's completely
fine, using the model.
We're not going to
be measuring time.
We're only going to be focusing
on how much space we're using.
Another example that we
gave is the PATH language,
where you're given a
graph, and a start node,
and a target node.
And you want to know, is there
a path in this directed graph
that goes from s to t?
And that's the
language that's also--
that language is in NL--
in fact, not known to be in L.
So the way that
would look, shifting
to an input in
the PATH language,
you would have a
graph represented,
say, by a sequence of edges,
and a start, and a target.
And the work tape would keep
track of the current node.
So the nondeterministic
machine would
guess a path that takes you
from s to t, node by node.
And the work tape would keep
track of the current node.
OK, so I hope you have this--
develop a little bit of an
intuition for these classes,
L and NL.
We're going to be spending
the entire lecture today
talking about that.
OK.
So as I mentioned, the L and NL
problem is an unsolved problem.
And it's very much analogous
to the P versus NP problem,
except, as I mentioned,
as we'll show,
that NL and its
complement end up
being the same, which
is not something
that seems to be the case
for NP, though we don't know.
Can we think of this as a
multi-head Turing machine?
I'm getting a question about
that, which is, I think,
you can.
In fact, that's an alternative
way that people look at it.
You can think of it as
having multiple-- you know,
a head basically needs log
space to store the location--
to store the location of
where that head would be.
So if you imagine having several
different heads on the input
tape, you can think
of a log space machine
as being sort of
a Turing machine
that has multiple heads
on the input table.
It's equivalent.
Good question.
So let's move on, then.
OK.
So one of the things we proved
last time was that anything
that you can do in L, you can
also do in polynomial time.
And I'll answer some of these
chat questions in a minute.
But the-- so the class
L is a subset of P.
This is easy to prove.
But I think it's nevertheless
important to see why it's true,
because it sort of sets
some definitions of things
that we're going to use later.
So in particular, we
really need to know
the notion of a configuration
of a log space machine
on an input.
So because the input
does not change,
we don't really
consider the input
to be part of the configuration.
The only thing that's--
the thing that's relevant
in the configuration
is the dynamic part of the
machine-- the state, the head
locations, and the
work tape contents.
So we're defining
that the configuration
for the machine on a
particular input, w,
is those four things--
state, the two head locations,
and the tape contents.
And the important thing to
keep in mind for this theorem
is that we have only
a polynomial number
of different configurations if
you just do the calculation.
The main part is the number
of different tape contents
as you can have, which is
exponential in the log n.
And that's a polynomial.
And so therefore, any machine
that runs in log space,
provided it always
holds, and we always
assume our machines
always hold, they
can only run for a
polynomial number of steps,
because that's as many different
configurations as they have.
If they ran for, say, an
exponential number of steps,
they would have to be
repeating configurations.
And then they would be looping.
OK, so there we go.
OK, so let me just get back--
so somebody asked me a question.
Which is harder?
P versus NP or L versus NL?
Completely no idea.
It's a-- I guess there was a
common line of thinking that
if you're going to--
that it's good to
try to think about--
if you're trying to
separate classes,
you might as well take
classes that are as far
apart as one another.
Like, if you're
trying to prove--
if you're comparing P different
from NP and P different
from PSPACE, maybe P
different from PSPACE
might be easier, because P and
PSPACE seem to be even further
apart than P and NP.
Nobody knows.
And I suspect that
there's something
fundamental about computation
that we just don't understand.
And then once somebody
makes a breakthrough
and solves one of those
problems, a lot of them
are going to get
solved in short order.
But again, it's
purely speculation.
OK, d.
What is d here? d would be
the size of the tape alphabet.
OK, so this is the number
of different tape contents
we have.
Good.
All right.
So let's continue on.
Another thing we mentioned
kind of quickly in passing,
but still an important fact,
is that Savitch's theorem
works down to the
level of log space--
same exact proof.
So that means that
nondeterministic log space
is contained in deterministic
log squared space,
because that's what Savitch's
theorem does for you.
It converts
nondeterministic machines
to deterministic
machines at the cost
of a squaring in the
amount of space you need.
And so I'm not going to
go through this in detail.
But the same picture that I
copied off an earlier slide
with a simple modification
is that instead of--
that I'm right down--
the size of the configuration
is going to be now log n,
because that's how big
the configurations are
when you have a nondeterministic
log space machine.
And so simulating that--
so this would be what
the tableau would
look like for an NL machine.
And then you can simulate
that in the same way
by trying all
possible intermediates
and then splitting it,
doing the top half and then
the bottom half.
We're using the space,
of course, recursively.
The amount of space
you're going to need
is going to be enough to store,
for one level of the recursion,
one configuration.
And that's order log space.
And then the number
of levels of recursion
is going to be another
factor of log n,
because that's log to
the running time, which
is going to be exponential in
log n, which is polynomial.
So the total amount of
space that you would need
would be log squared space.
Again, this is sort of saying
the proof of Savitch's theorem,
just over again.
So if it's coming
too fast for you,
just review the proof
of Savitch's theorem
and observe that it works,
even if the amount of space
that the machine--
that the nondeterministic
machine starts off with
is log space.
All right.
And last thing I was going
to-- last thing in the category
of a review is our theorem that
not only is all of L within P--
and that's kind of
trivial, kind of immediate.
You don't even have
to change the machine.
If you have a log space
machine for some language,
the very same machine is
a polynomial time machine
for that language,
because it can only
be running for a
polynomial amount of time.
But now, we have a
nondeterministic machine
for some language.
We're going to have
to change it to become
a deterministic machine that
runs in polynomial time.
And so we're going to give a
deterministic polynomial time
simulation of a nondeterministic
log space machine.
And we kind of did this last
time, but a little quickly.
So now, if we have some
nondeterministic log space
machine, so an M, which decides
the language A in log space,
we're going to show
how to simulate
that machine with a
deterministic polynomial time
machine.
And the key idea, which
is going to come up
in a later theorem, so good to
understand it not only here,
but to understand it for the
next theorem that's coming,
is the notion of a
configuration graph.
I was sort of thinking about
calling it a computation graph.
But now, on further
reflection, I
think configuration graph maybe
is the more suggestive term.
So let's stick with that.
So a configuration graph
for a machine on an input
is just a set of
all configurations
that the machine has, all
the possible different
configurations the
machine can have,
with edges connecting
configurations that correspond
to legal moves of the machine.
So here is some configuration.
This is a snapshot of the
machine at a moment in time.
Here is some other
configuration,
another snapshot of the
machine at a moment n time.
And you're going to draw
an edge between ci and cj
if cj could follow
in one step from ci.
And you could tell by just
looking at the configurations
whether that could be possible.
Obviously, the head has
to be one place over in cj
from where it was in ci.
And it has to be
updated according
to the rules of the machine.
So you can tell whether--
so you could fill
out this graph.
You could write down all
the possible configurations.
And you can put the edges down.
Now, the point is that when
we have a log space machine,
we don't have too many
possible configurations.
There's only a
polynomial number.
So the size of this whole
graph is polynomial.
So our polynomial
time simulation
is going to write down
that entire configuration
graph of the log space
machine on its input.
There [INAUDIBLE]
many configurations.
There can be only
polynomially many.
So you can write down all those
configurations as the nodes
and then go look at
each pair of nodes,
whether this configuration could
lead to that configuration.
According to-- it's a
nondeterministic machine.
So a configuration could go to
several different locations--
there could be several
different ways to go.
But those are just several
different outgoing edges
from a particular node in
this graph representing
the configuration,
which might have
several different
legal successors
in the nondeterministic
computation.
OK.
Now, the important thing here
is that M accepts its input, w,
exactly when there
is a path [INAUDIBLE]
configuration graph
that takes you
from the start configuration
to the accept configuration.
And as I mentioned,
let's assume,
as we've been doing,
that the machine--
I should have put it
here, but I didn't.
But the machine, when
it is about to accept,
it erases its work tape
and moves both of its heads
to the home position at
the left end of the tape.
So there's just one
accepting configuration
you have to worry about.
It just makes life simpler.
So there's going to be
a start configuration,
a single accept configuration
in this configuration graph.
And now there's going to be
a path, indicated here, that
connects the start configuration
to the accept configuration
if and only if M accepts
w, because that path
is the sequence
of configurations
that the machine
would go through
if you launched it on w.
It would start at the start.
And there might be several
different ways to go.
But if there is one of them
that leads you to an accept,
that's going to correspond to
a branch of the computation
that it's accepting.
OK, so that tells us what the
polynomial time algorithm is.
On input w, you construct
that configuration graph for M
on w, G sub Mw.
And you test whether there's
a path from c start to c
accept using any polynomial
time depth-first search
or breadth-first search
algorithm for testing
whether there's a
connection path in a graph.
And if there is such
a path, you accept,
because that means the
machine M accepted.
And if there was no path,
you reject, because then M
must have not accepted.
And therefore, you have a
polynomial time simulation
of your nondeterministic
log space machine M, OK?
How are we doing?
OK, so that tells us that
NL is contained within P.
And also, L is contained
within NL, as before.
So we have kind of this
hierarchy of classes.
Now, you can even talk
about, not only is L
different from NL, even
is L different from P?
Is it possible that
anything that you
can do in polynomial time,
you can do [INAUDIBLE] space?
Don't know.
Open question.
OK, getting a very good
question here just now.
Why is this construction
taking log space?
It doesn't.
This construction
takes polynomial time.
This algorithm here
is not a polynomial--
this is not a log space
algorithm that I'm giving you.
I'm giving you a
polynomial time algorithm
for simulating a
nondeterministic log space
machine.
Now, later on-- I don't want
to confuse the issue right now.
For this particular
slide, all I need to do
is construct that graph
in polynomial time.
It's a polynomial size graph.
I can't store that whole
graph in a log space memory.
OK, so question here--
we can see that listing
out the nodes and edges
would be polynomial time.
But how do we actually
provide structure
to this graph representation?
I don't even know
what that means.
So if you can
clarify that for me,
then maybe I can
try to answer it.
But a graph is just a list
of nodes and a list of edges.
After that, we know
what the graph is.
I mean, you may like a picture.
But the machine
doesn't need a picture.
Our definition of-- we
just represent these things
as strings, in the end.
So please clarify
if you want me to--
I'll answer it the
next at the next pause.
I'm grateful for all the
questions, because I'm sure,
any question that any of
you have, another 20 of you
also have.
So questions are good.
Don't be bashful.
And also ask the TAs
if I become overloaded.
OK, now we're going to shift
gears into some new material.
All right.
We're going to talk
about the notion that--
sort of thinking about,
analogous to the P versus NP
problem, where there were
these NP-complete problems,
now we have the L
versus NL problem.
There are going to be
an NL-complete problems
that kind of capture the
essence of NL the way
NP-complete problems
capture the essence of NP,
in a sense, in that all
of the problems in NP
are reducible to them.
So they're kind of like
the hardest NP problems.
Here, we're going to have
exactly analogous situations
for NL, where we're
going to show problems
where all other NL problems
are reducible to them.
So if you can kind
of solve one of them,
like solve one of these
NL-complete problems in log
space deterministically, then
you solve all of NL problems
in log space deterministically.
So it's a very
similar-looking definition
to what we had before.
It's NL complete if it's in NL.
And then all other languages
in NL should be reducible.
But now, we have a new notion
here, with an L instead of a P.
Now, before, when we talked
about NP completeness,
we had polynomial
time reducibility.
That's not going
to work anymore,
because if you remember,
NL is a subset of P.
So all NL languages
are polynomial--
are languages in P. And
if we're talking about--
if we use polynomial
time reducibility,
all languages in P are
reducible to each other.
We need to have a notion
of reducibility which is
kind of weaker than the class.
And so polynomial
time reducibility just
would not work here,
because everything
would become NL complete,
is reducible to each other.
So we need to have
a weaker notion.
We're going to use log
space reducibility,
which we have to define.
So here, for that,
we're going to have
to talk about the
notion of a function
that you can compute
in log space.
And it's a little tricky here.
Just like when we talked
about language recognition
in log space, where
we had the work tape
had to be smaller
than the input tape,
because the inputs can be large.
The work area is small.
Now the output
also could be large
relative to the work area.
So we're going to have a
three-tape model, where there's
the input is going
to be a read-only,
the output is a write-only--
it's like a printer.
It's something you
can only write on,
but you can't read back,
because otherwise, you
could cheat by using the
output as a kind of storage.
And then you have your
storage area, which
is your read-write work tape.
OK, so this-- we'll call this--
the traditional name of this
is a log space transducer.
So it converts
inputs to outputs,
but uses only log space
for its working memory.
OK, so the input tape
stores n bit-- n symbols.
The work tape stores log n
symbols, order log n symbols.
And then we have
the output tape.
You may want to
think about how big--
there's going to be a check-in
coming to kind of ask you,
how big could the output be?
But we'll save that
for the end if you--
you can mull that over if
you want to think ahead.
OK.
So we think of a
log space transducer
as computing a
function, which is just
a mapping from the
input to the output
that the transducer
provides for you.
A transducer is a deterministic
machine, by the way.
So you take the transducer.
You give it w.
And you turn it on.
And then it halts with f
of w on its output tape.
That's what it means to be
computing the function f, OK?
And we'll say that A is log
space reducible to B, using
the l subscript symbol on the
less than or equal to sign,
if it's mapping reducible
to B, but by a reduction
function that's
computable in log
space, just the
same way we define
polynomial time reducibility.
But there, we insisted that
the reduction function was
computable in polynomial time.
OK.
Just quickly, I got
a question again.
Why log space here?
Because polynomial time would
be too powerful for doing
reductions internal to
P. Every language in P
is reducible to every
other language in P.
And so everything in NL would
be reducible to everything else
in L with a polynomial
time reducibility.
And so that would not be
an interesting notion.
We have to use a weaker
notion than that, a weaker
kind of reduction,
using a weaker model,
so that you don't get--
otherwise, the
reduction function
would be able to
answer whether--
would be able to solve
the problem A itself
if we had a polynomial
time reduction,
and we're mapping things from
NL to other problems in NL.
The reduction would
solve the problem.
And that's not what you want.
The reduction should
be constrained only
to be able to do simple
transformations on the problem,
not to solve the problem.
Anyway, you have
to look at that.
This is an issue that's come
up before when we talked about,
what's the right
notion of reduction
to use for PSPACE completeness?
Same exact discussion.
OK.
Now, there is an
issue here, though,
that we have to be careful of.
When we have A being log space
reducible to B, and B in L,
then what you want--
if A is log space
reducible to B and B in L,
then you want A
to be in L. That's
the same pattern we've
always had for reductions.
If A is reducible to B, and
B is easy, then A is easy.
So here, the notion of
easy is being an L. Now,
if you remember the proof
of that we had from before,
which I'll just
put out for you, is
that to show a log space solver
for A, you take an input, w.
And now, if A is reducible to
B, you compute the reduction.
And then you run
the decider for B.
So if we're assuming A is
reducible to B, and B is in L,
so B has a log
space decider, you
take your w, which you
want to know, is it in A?
You map it over to a B problem
using the reduction function.
And then you solve it
using the decider for B.
And you give the same answer.
Now, this actually
doesn't work anymore,
or it doesn't work
in an obvious way,
because, if you're
following me--
I hope most of you are--
there is a problem here, which--
because we're trying to give
a log space algorithm for A.
And that algorithm is going
to be computing this reduction
function, mapping w to f of w.
f of w might itself
be very large,
as this picture suggests here.
You may not be able
to store f of w
in the log space memory for
the machine that's deciding A.
So this is an
obstacle that we need
to solve in order to prove
this theorem, which we need,
because that's the whole
justification for doing
these reducibilities--
should be a familiar-looking
kind of line
to what we've seen before.
So we don't have
space to store f of w.
What do we do?
And I'll also
mention that this is
going to be relevant to one
of your homework problems.
So what do we do?
We don't have space to store
the intermediate result
that we need in order
to solve the problem.
We started with w.
Now we'd need to test
if f of w is in B.
That can run in log space.
But just simply getting
your hands on f of w--
what do you do about that?
So what we're going to do is
the following, is the decider--
the decider for B,
which needs f of w,
because it's deciding
if f of w is in B--
it doesn't need all of f of w
sitting there in front of it
all at once.
If you think about how the
Turing machine operates
on its input, it only looks
at one symbol at a time.
It starts out reading the
leftmost symbol of f of w,
then maybe it moves
its head right
and moves to the second
symbol of f of w,
then the third symbol of f of w.
Maybe it gets up to the
10th symbol of f of w.
Maybe it moves his head back
and goes to the ninth symbol
and the eighth symbol.
But the Turing machine's
head, which is deciding B,
only looks at one symbol
of f of w at a time.
So instead of writing
down all of f of w,
the idea is that we
are going to compute
the individual symbols of
f of w that we need only
at the moment we need them.
So if the decider
for B is reading
the 10th symbol of f of w, we
fire up the transducer on w.
And as it's writing
out its output, which
we don't have space
to store anymore,
we throw away all
of the output values
until we get to the 10th one.
And then we say, ah, the
10th one is whatever,
is a c, whatever the value is.
Now we feed that into
the decider for B.
We can now simulate that
decider for one more step.
Now the decider says,
all right, now I
need the 11th symbol of f of w.
OK, now we can run that
machine for one more place.
But if it needs--
but we don't even have to do it.
I think the better way to
think about it is, every time
that decider for B
needs another symbol,
we start the transducer
over again and just keep--
throw away everything except
for that one symbol output
that we need.
So every time we do another
step of simulating B,
we're going to have to rerun the
transducer from the beginning,
just to recompute
that, or compute maybe
for the first time, or recompute
it if we need it subsequently.
This is going to be
slow, but we don't
care, to recompute that
symbol that the simulator--
that the decider
for B requires, OK?
So I'm saying that over here.
Recompute the symbols
of f of w as needed.
OK, so let me-- let's take
a couple of questions.
And then we're going
to move to a check-in.
So somebody's asking, why did
we have to introduce transducer
for log space
reducibility when we
didn't do it for polynomial
time reducibility?
We could have for polynomial
time reducibility.
But we didn't need to, because
we could just all do it
on the same tape.
The problem is, for log
space, the tape is--
the work tape is too small to
hold the input on the output.
So we can't-- since
we're only working--
we have a log n bound that
we have to work within.
We need to separate
those functions
from the work functions, the
input function and the output
function.
So if we have more than the
amount of resource we have,
either time or space
was at least n,
then we could just
lump them all together
and have that one tape
do multiple functions.
And somebody's
asked me here, yeah,
this is mapping
reducibility, this m.
This is from the
notion we saw before.
OK.
Does f of w lie on
the input tape of B?
Well, yes.
So we are-- good question.
So f of w--
you know, because
what are we doing?
We're trying to
find a decider for A
here, using the decider for
B and the mapping from A
to B, the reduction from A to B.
So the decider for B
expects to find its input
on an input tape.
That input is
going to be f of w.
But we have to get
the effect of that
without actually writing
down that input tape,
because we don't
have enough room
to write down the input
tape for the decider--
for the B decider, because
that could be very large.
And we only have--
we have no place
to put the f of w.
So think about
what's going on here.
We're making a log space
machine whose input
is w, has to compute f of
w as an intermediate value,
to feed it into the B decider.
That is not going to be possible
to hold onto that whole f of w
at one--
altogether, because
it's too big.
But that doesn't matter.
We don't need it.
We only needed one symbol at a
time, which we can recompute.
OK, so let's see.
So somebody says,
can we just ensure
that the output tape
is order n so we
don't need to use more
tape than the input?
Order n is still
going to be too big.
Where are you going
to put that output?
Even if it's just
order n-- first of all,
the answer is no, we
can't, because there
are going to be reductions
which are bigger than that.
But the other question
is, can we just
ensure that the
output is order n?
You can't put the output
on the input tape.
The input tape is read-only.
The output tape is write-only.
So there's no place to--
even if the output is
just as big as the input,
it doesn't help you.
If the output is only log
n, OK, then we could do it.
But that's not going to
be interesting for us.
You're going to need,
for these large space
reductions, big outputs,
as we'll see in a minute.
What's the running time for
this log space reduction?
It's all going to be polynomial.
It's all going to be
a log space algorithm.
So it's all going
to be polynomial.
Is there any NP
completeness reduction
which can be done in log space?
All of the NP--
all typical NP
completeness reductions,
those polynomial time
reductions, they all
can be done in log
space, because they are--
reductions tend to be very
simple transformations.
And log space is going to
be enough to do all of them.
OK.
I can't answer the
second part of that.
That's too complicated.
And I think we should move on.
So let's look at the
first check-in here.
So if we have a long
space transducer that
computes f, and if you
feed it inputs of length n,
how big can the
outputs be, actually?
So why don't you think about
that and give me an answer?
I'll give you a minute
to answer this question.
Oh, this is a tough one.
Let me just say up
front, there are--
I struggle with this lecture,
because some-- especially the
stuff in the second
half, it's kind of hard.
I wouldn't say it's technical.
But conceptually, I think
some of the material
is a little harder,
maybe in part
because people are
not used to thinking
about memory complexity
or space complexity,
even though I don't see why--
I mean, I think it's
an important resource
to be considering.
But I think it's less common.
And I think there's some
discomfort with that.
OK, so we're just
about done here.
Five more seconds, please.
All right, about to wrap.
Wrap the check-in.
1, 2, 3.
All right.
So yes, the correct answer is c.
As I mentioned,
we're going to want
to have outputs that
are larger than log n.
And there's no reason
why they wouldn't
be able to be larger than log
n, according to the definition
that I gave you.
There's no bound on the output.
We're only measuring the
running space of this algorithm
in terms of its work tape.
The input and output
tapes don't count.
So they can be more than log n.
They can be more than n.
Polynomial is the right answer.
Why?
Because a log space transducer,
if you just ignore the output,
is just an ordinary
log space machine.
And it can only run for a
polynomial number of steps
without it end up
going into a loop.
The same argument
that we gave for that
before applies here as well.
So if it's going to exceed a
polynomial number of steps,
it's never going to hold.
And so that's going to be--
not allow it-- it's got to halt
with the output on the output
tape.
And so it'll be disqualified
as a log space transducer
if it doesn't halt. So it
can't be anything longer
than polynomial.
It's a good thing to think
about, to understand.
OK, so let's continue.
So we're going to show that the
PATH problem is NL complete.
Now, we defined NL completeness.
And we've seen the
PATH problem before.
And we're now going to show
that PATH occupies a very
special position for
NL, namely that it's
an NL-complete problem.
So if you can solve the PATH
problem deterministically
in log space, you have
gotten a big result.
No one knows how to do that.
And it would collapse
all of NL down
to log space if you could
do PATH in log space
deterministically.
OK, so let's see why that is.
So first of all, the two
components of being complete
are being in the language
and the reduction part.
So in the language,
we've shown already.
Now, we want to show that
for any other language in NL,
it's going to be log
space reducible to PATH.
In a certain sense, this
may not feel so surprising,
thinking back to our proof
that NL is a subset of P,
because we managed
to convert any NL
machine, the running of any
NL machine, to a PATH problem
that the polynomial time
machine then solved.
And so it's really the same
idea that says that PATH really
captures any NL machine.
The computation
of any NL machine
really can be seen as
a PATH problem, where
the nodes are the
configurations of the machine.
So let's just see how--
let me just try to go
through that if that
wasn't super clear, which
I'm not sure it was.
So suppose we have a
machine decided by--
a language decided by a
nondeterministic-- an NL
machine, a nondeterministic
machine in log space.
Again, I should have
put this before.
But we're going to modify
M to erase its work tape
and move its head to the
left end on accepting.
So it has a unique
accepting configuration.
Now I'm going to give it
the log space reduction that
maps our language A, which is
in NL, to the PATH language.
So thinking about
what that means,
I'm going to take an input, w,
which may or may not be in A,
and produce for you a graph with
a start and target node, start
and target notes, where w is
going to be in the language
if and only if G has
a path from s to t.
And what do you think
that graph is going to be?
That's going to be
the configuration
graph for the machine
that decides A, OK?
So that is how
it's going to look.
So maybe here's a picture.
Right.
So f of w, where w, again, is
your problem about membership
in A, is going to
become a problem
about membership in PATH.
And it's just going to be the
configuration graph for M on w.
Now, what's left is to show
that we can do this conversion
with a log space transducer.
So it's a log space
computable reduction.
So let's just try to go
through that quickly--
conceptually, not super hard.
So here's our transducer.
Let's just think about
what it needs to do.
It needs to take an input,
w, and convert that f
of w to this thing here--
computation graph of M on w--
the configuration
graph M on w, the start
and accept configuration.
So that's going to look
like this down here.
That's what we want
to eventually appear
on the output tape.
So the way we're going
to achieve that-- we only
have a small log space,
order log space work tape.
And the way we're going to be
able to produce this output
is--
the configuration graph is just
a series of edges, which are--
say, you can go from
this configuration
to that configuration
in one step.
So what we're going to
do is, on our work tape,
we're going to go through
all possible pairs
of configurations, again, just
in some like odometer order,
just by looking at all possible
strings, really, of length
order log n that are
big enough to represent
two configurations.
Every once in a
while, it's going
to be actually a pair
of configurations.
At that point, we look at those
two configurations, look at M,
and see, can this configuration
go to that configuration?
If yes, you print it
out on the output tape.
If no, you just move on to the
next pair of configurations.
And then, at the end, you
write down on the start
and accept configurations.
So I've indicated that here.
Here is the transducer.
It says, on input w, for all
pairs of configurations, that--
now, this is getting written
down on the work tape--
you output those pairs
which are legal moves for M.
And then finally, you output
the start and the accept.
That's it.
So let's just see.
Let me take any questions here.
Why do we need special
accept state for M?
Well, we want to have--
I think you mean
accepting configuration.
I just want to have a--
I don't want to
have a multiplicity
of different possible
accepting configurations,
because then it's not
really a PATH problem.
Then it becomes a question
of, can I get from the start
to one of those
nodes representing
accepting configurations?
That's a little messy.
I could fix it.
But the simplest
fix is just to make
there be a single
accepting configuration.
Well, why do I output
start and accept
at the end of the output tape?
That's the way I write
down my PATH problem.
It's a graph, followed by a
start node and a target node.
So I have to follow that form.
I'm not sure what you're asking.
You want me to put that first?
I'm not sure what the--
or why at all?
Because it has to be a--
here it is.
Here's the output
I'm looking for.
OK.
Do the three-- do
the read-write work
tape here store pointers
to configuration
or some sort of counter?
No, they store the
actual configuration.
The configuration for M is--
just think about what it is.
It's a log space size object.
It's a tape for
M. It's a location
of its heads and its state.
So you could kind of write down
that stuff right over here,
on the left side of this--
this left slot.
And on the right
slot, you're going
to write another
configuration for M on w.
And you're going to just put
the edges in accordingly.
OK, so somebody-- did that help?
Somebody, again, is asking, why
is the configuration only log
space?
It's just a tape.
It's a log space tape.
That's the main thing in the
configuration of the tape.
On the read-write
work tape, do we only
write two
configurations at once?
Yeah.
We're just writing
down a candidate edge
that we're going to output
onto the output tape.
So that's why we have
two configurations.
I want to know, can I get
from this configuration
to that configuration?
If yes, I print it out,
print out that pair.
That's an edge in
my configuration
graph, which is what I'm
supposed to be outputting here.
Can there be multiple--
OK, why don't we move on?
Again, direct
questions to our TAs,
who would be more than
happy to help you.
And we will-- let
me just quickly
give-- we're running a
little tight here time-wise.
But let's just see.
Here's an example of showing
some other problem is
NL complete.
You have a homework
problem on that.
So I thought I wanted
to give you an example.
Maybe we can just defer
this to the recitation.
So maybe we'll try to do this
a little quickly to save us
on time.
But the 2SAT problem, which
is just like the 3SAT problem,
except with two
literals per clause--
curiously, the complement
of that problem,
so the unsatisfiable
formulas, that
form an NL-complete language.
And so first of all, you
have to show it's in NL.
We're not going to do that.
It's a nice exercise.
It's not totally trivial to do.
But you might want to try that.
We're going to show that PATH
is reducible to the complement
of 2SAT.
We've got to give a reduction
that converts graphs
to formulas, where there is a
PATH, now, when the formula is
unsatisfied.
And what's going to
happen is the PATH
is going to correspond to
a sequence of implications
in the formula, which
yields a contradiction
and forces it to be unsatisfied.
Again, this is going
to come a little fast.
And then maybe we can discuss it
over the break, which is next.
So every node in G is
going to have associated
variable in the formula.
So there's a variable for
every one of the nodes.
For every edge,
there's going to be
a clause of implication
connecting those two
associated nodes.
So if there's an
edge from u to v,
then there's going to be an
implication in the formula that
says, if xu is true,
then xv is true.
And note that that's equivalent
to the more conventional way
[INAUDIBLE] xu complement or xv.
These are logically equivalent.
So I'm not cheating you here in
terms of being a 2SAT problem.
They really just look like this.
And lastly, I'm going to
put two additional clauses.
It's [INAUDIBLE] x for
the start variable--
from the start node, s--
here, s.
I want to force
that one to be true.
So it's x-- since I want to
have exactly two per clause,
that's xs or xs.
So that forces x--
that variable true.
And lastly, if t is true,
that's going to force the--
if xt is true, that's going
to force xs to be false.
So now, if there's actually
a path in the graph that
goes from s to t,
there's going to be
a sequence of implications,
starting now with s being true,
forcing other things
being true, including
forcing t to be true, which
then forces s to be false.
And that's our contradiction,
which shows that the formula
cannot be satisfied.
So now, you have to
prove that this works.
As I said, for the forward
direction, if there is a path,
you follow the implications
to get a contradiction.
For the reverse-- let
me not spend time here.
I'll leave this to you
to think about offline.
But if there is
no path, there is
a way of assigning the
variables to true and false
to make a satisfying
assignment to the formula.
So that gives the
other direction, OK?
And you can show it's
computable in log space.
That's very simple, because
a very simple transformation
there, OK?
So I think we're going
to move on to the break.
And I'm happy to take questions
at this point about this.
Does the configuration, going
back, include the input?
No.
The configuration does not--
as I said, the
configuration for M on w
is the state, the head
positions, and the work tape
contents, not the input tape,
because then you would be--
it's not there for a reason.
The input is huge.
But you don't need
the input there,
because the input is going
to be constant for everybody.
Everybody can look at that
input, which is a fixed, sort
of external thing.
Somebody's asking me, are
there NP-complete problems in--
there are definitely
NP-complete [INAUDIBLE]..
I don't know-- there are some
problems in number theory where
it's--
like factoring, where we
don't know the status,
somewhere between P
and NP, formulated
as a language, of course.
But there are
problems in solving
certain kinds of equations,
low-degree equations,
that I don't remember now
if [INAUDIBLE] actually
known to be NP complete.
Now, you asked about NL
complete [INAUDIBLE]..
I don't know if there are
NL-complete number theory
problems.
Oh, good question.
Somebody's asking
me, does NL also
have an alternative
definition using
certificates or witnesses?
Yeah.
Yes, sort of.
For NL, you can make a
certificate, which is, again,
polynomial size certificate.
But it has to be--
you're only allowed
to read it with a one-way head.
So it's like a
one-way certificate.
So it has to be-- you can only
process it in a certain way.
That's a nice exercise,
actually, itself.
But anyway, let us--
we are now done.
And we're going to move back.
We're going to continue.
So everybody return.
This is what's
next on the agenda,
proving that NL equals coNL.
This is a hard proof.
I'm going to try to break
it down as much as I can.
And let's hope you get--
I hope you get it.
I'll try to be as
helpful as I can.
OK.
But if you're finding it
tough, you won't be alone.
So first of all,
we're going to show--
the way we're
going to solve this
is by showing that
the complement of PATH
is solvable in NL, because
the complement of PATH is--
just as PATH is complete
for NL, the complement
is complete for coNL.
And so by doing
that problem in NL,
we're going to reduce
all of-- all of coNL
will be reducible
to problems in NL.
And so therefore,
we'll be in NL. coNL
will be then inside NL.
And then NL is going
to be equal to coNL.
If that sequence of logical
connections, is not clear.
Don't worry.
The point is that we want
[INAUDIBLE] go back and figure
out why that's enough later.
But what this means
is we want to give
a nondeterministic
machine, which
will accept when there
is no path from s to t.
OK?
And please don't
say, why don't we
just take the machine for
PATH and flip the answer?
You can't do that with a
nondeterministic machine.
So you better-- if you're
thinking that that's allowed,
go back and review
nondeterminism.
So you want to make a
nondeterministic machine, which
is going to accept
when there's no path.
So some branch is going to
make a sequence of guesses.
And it has to be sure
that there's no path.
And then it's going to be--
and then it can accept
when there's no path.
Now, if you can find a way
of like making a separator,
something that cuts the graph
in half and separates s from t,
then you would be good.
The only problem is there's
no obvious way of doing that,
because those kind
of separators,
even if they were
[INAUDIBLE] probably too
big to write down in log space.
So I'm going to give you
a completely different way
of doing it.
And I'm going to make-- this is
a little different presentation
than what's in the book.
I think hopefully, this is a
little longer, and therefore,
a little clearer.
We'll see.
So first of all,
I'm going to define
a notion of a nondeterministic
machine computing a function.
And that's a simple idea.
What you want is, on
the different branches--
so you have some function,
f, which has, for every w,
there's an output, f of w.
And the nondeterministic
machine can
operate that on all
of its branches,
it's allowed to either give f of
w or say reject, meaning punt,
or say, I don't know.
So every branch has to
give the right answer.
So all the branches that
give an answer have to agree,
because there's only
one right answer.
All the branches
that give an answer
have to give the right answer,
or they can say, I don't know.
The only thing is you have
to also say that at least one
of the branches actually
gives an answer.
So somebody cannot reject.
Somebody cannot
say, I don't know.
So at least one of the
branches gives an answer and--
gives the answer.
And all the other branches
can either give the answer,
or they can say--
they can just reject.
But there's no
notion of accepting.
There's just a notion of this
nondeterministic machine,
on some branches,
giving the output value,
and other branches just
punting and saying reject.
Maybe reject is the wrong word.
I could just say punt.
All right.
So we're going to be talking
about functions that you
can compute with
nondeterministic machines,
with NL machines in particular.
All right?
So we're going to look at
this path function now.
Now, this is not exactly the
same as the PATH language.
This is a function here,
written with lowercase.
So given a graph,
s and t, I'm going
to say yes if there is a path
and no if there's no path.
And this is a
function now, which
is going to output yes
or no, not a language.
This is a function.
It's very closely related.
I understand.
So if you can
solve the function,
you can do the language.
But what we're going to
give is a NL machine,
a nondeterministic
machine, which is
going to compute this function.
And therefore, you can use
that to do the PATH language.
Two important things for us
is, if G is some graph, well,
here's the starting node, s.
R is all of the nodes
that you can reach from s.
This is some
collection of nodes.
And c, which stands
for count, is
the number of reachable nodes.
So I've written that
down here more--
if you like it more formally.
R is the number--
is the collection of
nodes for which there's
a path from s to the node.
And c is the size of R. So you
have to understand these two,
because we're going to
be playing with this
for the next three slides.
OK.
Now, first of all, this is kind
of a little bit of an exercise
theorem.
But it's still going to be
a useful fact that we're
going to end up needing later.
But it's also a
little bit of just
to test your understanding.
Suppose there's some
NL machine which
computes this path function.
So on the different branches
of the nondeterminism,
given a graph, G,
s, and t, there
are going to be some branches
which may output yes,
or some branches
that may output no.
And other branches
might say, I don't know.
But the machine always has to
give the right answer if it's
going to give any answer.
So all branches either have
to say yes, or all branches--
all branches have
to say yes or punt,
or all branches have
to say no or punt,
because one of those answers is
going to be the right answer.
So suppose I have a way
of computing path by an NL
machine.
Then can I also compute the--
can I make some other
NL machine which
computes the count, the
number of nodes reachable?
So if I can test if
a node is reachable,
can I figure out how
many nodes are reachable?
This is supposed to be easy.
This is kind of a little
bit of a practice.
So if I can figure out
if nodes are reachable,
yes or no, then I
can say, figure out
how many nodes are reachable.
You just go through
them one by one,
testing if they're reachable,
and count the ones that are.
That's all I have in mind.
So start with a counter
that's set to 0 initially.
And go through each of
the nodes of G one by one.
And I use my NL machine
that computes path.
That's what I mean by this part.
So I test it.
If the NL machine says
yes, there is a path,
then I increase the counter.
And if it says there's
no path, then I just
continue without
increasing the counter.
Now, when I'm
running my NL machine
to compute this function,
that NL machine might punt,
might reject sometimes
on some branches.
That's OK.
I'm also allowed.
I'm also an NL machine.
I'm computing a value.
And I also might punt
on some branches.
So at the end, I'm going
to output that count, OK?
So what I'm going to prove
next is the converse of this.
And that's-- and that's
the magical hard part,
that if I can compute the
count, then I can do the test
of whether individual nodes are
connected, have a path from s.
OK, so let's just see.
Somebody is asking if
nondeterministic machines--
so like M is not
allowed to loop?
No.
If a machine, if any
one of these machines,
like an NL machine, loops,
it's going to be going forever.
That's not allowed.
So no looping.
I'm not sure why that's
relevant, but no looping.
But what I'm more
worried is that you
understand this theorem here.
I think we have a
check-in coming.
Let's see.
OK.
This might be helpful.
So consider the statement
that PATH complement is NL.
That's what we're
trying to prove,
and also that some NL machine
can compute the path function.
These are going to
be related facts.
Which one can we prove
from the other easily?
I mean, they're both
going to be true.
So in some sense, it's trivial.
But I want to know,
which one can we
prove kind of immediately
without doing much work?
That I can solve this
PATH problem in NL,
the complement of the
or that I can compute
the path function in NL?
So what do you think?
OK, almost done here?
Yeah.
Ending.
You guys didn't do well.
That's OK.
Actually, the right answer is c.
Most of you got that if I can
solve the path function, so
the yes-no value, I can use that
now to solve both PATH and PATH
complement.
That seems more clear cut.
But suppose I can solve the
PATH complement problem in NL.
And I also know I can solve
the PATH problem in NL.
That, we've already shown.
So knowing both of those, if
I'm given a G, s, and t, what
I can do is
nondeterministically pick which
of those two directions.
You know, I pick--
I'm going to guess,
well, it's in PATH,
or it's in the
complement of PATH.
So there are two different
nondeterministic ways to go.
One of those is going to
always end up rejecting.
And so that's going
to end up punting.
The other direction is
going to sometimes end up
accepting and sometimes punting.
And based upon whether
which side ends up--
one or the other is going
to have some accept--
is going to be accepting.
And so the one
that's accepting is
going to tell me whether
to answer yes or no.
So actually, both
directions, both implications
follow pretty easily.
OK.
Anyway, let's try to show--
this is the hard part.
And we have five minutes.
Let's see how far we can get.
So this theorem works by magic.
So it kind of blew everybody's
mind when it first came out.
So let's just see.
It's really not that hard.
But it's sort of--
it's kind of twisted.
So suppose some
machine can compute
c, the count, the
number reachable from s.
I'm going to use that to
solve path, the path function,
to test, yes, I can output
yes if there is a path
or no, there is no
path, for each node t.
So if I know how many
nodes are reachable,
then I can solve now for
individual nodes, which is
strange that you can do that.
Now, I'm not telling
you how to compute c.
That's for later, which
I probably won't get to.
But just pretend we
can somehow figure out
what the count is of the
number of reachable nodes, OK?
So here is my nondeterministic
algorithm for computing path.
First, I'm going to compute
c, or let's say c is given.
And now, maybe the
best thing to do
is to try to give you
the idea up front.
What we're going to do, since
we're a little short on time,
what we're going to do
is, suppose I tell you,
there are, in this graph,
100 nodes reachable from s.
So c is 100.
There's 100 reachable nodes.
Now I want to know--
I say, well, I don't really--
that's all very nice.
But I'd like to know
this particular node, t.
Is that reachable from s?
Now, I'm a
nondeterministic machine.
Now, if t was
reachable, then I'd
be fine, because
nondeterministically, I
don't even care about the 100.
I take, nondeterministically,
on some branch, starting from s,
I'm going to hit t.
And that branch is
going to say yes.
The other branches,
maybe they'll punt.
But some branch is going
to get the right answer.
The problem is, suppose
t is not reachable.
Then you want some
branch to say no.
And how could that
branch ever say no,
unless it's sure that
t is not reachable?
And how can one branch be sure?
The idea is this.
Suppose I know that there
are 100 reachable nodes.
What I'm going to do
nondeterministically is I'm
going to guess those
100 nodes, one by one.
You can't store them all,
because it could be--
100 could be a big number.
I'm going to guess
them one by one.
I'm going to guess them.
And every time I
guess a node, I'm
going to prove it's reachable
by guessing the path that
shows it's reachable.
So I'm going to guess 100 nodes,
prove that they're reachable,
and then see, was t of
those reachable nodes?
If it was, well, then
I would have found it,
and I would know to say yes.
But if t was not one
of the 100 reachable
nodes, and I know
there's only 100--
so if t is not one
of those nodes--
in other words, if I found them
all, and t wasn't one of them,
then I know it's not reachable.
And that's how,
using the count, I
can be sure that certain
nodes are not reachable,
because I just find all the ones
that are, prove that they are,
check that the count agrees
with what I was given,
and then say no, t
is not reachable,
if it's not one of
those nodes that I've
found to be reachable, which
adds up to my given count.
That's the whole idea.
Of course, how do
you get the count?
Oddly enough, it's
kind of the same idea
repeated over and over again.
But I guess we'll have
to do that next time.
So let's just write this down.
And we'll kind of use
it as the beginning
of Thursday's lecture.
So we're going to go through
each node u, one by one.
Now we're going to
guess, for each node,
whether there's a
path to it or not.
So I'm going to call
it either p or n.
Again, this is now--
think about my 100 nodes.
I'm going to be
guessing all 100 nodes.
I'm going to
nondeterministically
pick a path from that node
that I guess is reachable.
So if I guess a node,
there is a path.
I'm going to confirm there's
a path by nondeterministically
picking it.
If I don't find
that path, I just
reject punt on that branch.
If that path that
I found actually
led me to t, so u, that
node that I'm working on,
is currently t, then
I know to accept.
But otherwise, I'm just going
to count the number of nodes
that I find are reachable.
If I've guessed that
u is not reachable,
I'm just going to skip it.
At the end, I see
whether the number
of nodes that I
have determined are
reachable agrees with
my original count, c.
So does k equal c or not?
If it doesn't equal,
they're not equal,
then I didn't find all
the reachable nodes.
I didn't guess right.
And so I punt.
I say, well, bad branch
of the nondeterminism.
I just give up.
But some branch of
the nondeterminism
is going to guess all of
the correct nodes which
are reachable.
And then, if t hadn't been
found already to be one of them,
at this point, I know
t is not reachable.
And so I can output no.
OK?
So that's the whole thing.
What is m? m is the-- yeah,
good question. m is the number
of nodes of the graph.
I should have said that.
So you don't want to go-- you
don't want to get into a loop.
So you better cut off
your picking of a path
to some cutoff value.
So you're going to
cut it off at m,
which is the number
of nodes, which
is going to be long enough.
Actually, we're going to play
with that in a bit later, but--
OK, let's just see.
How do I know I did not
visit the same node twice
when counting?
Because I'm just going
to go through all
of the nodes in some order.
Pick any order.
The nodes appear in some
order in the representation
of the graph on the input.
So any old order--
I'm just going to go
through the nodes in order.
Therefore, I'm never going
to see the same node twice.
What does step 4 mean?
So step 4 is--
step 4 means, for each
node, I'm guessing
that that node either
has a path to it from s
or does not have a
path to it from s.
So kind of thinking about
it, the original-- we're
out of time.
So why don't I--
I'm happy to discuss
this in the office hours.
I'm just going to skip
over the rest of the slides
here and review.
We have a missing check-in.
Let's just-- I want to
make sure everybody's
got all their check-ins here.
So why don't we just--
if we know NL is equal
to coNL, we also-- we
showed 2SAT complement
is NL complete.
It also then follows that
2SAT itself is NL complete,
because NL equals coNL.
So I'm going to give
you the answer to this
just, because I want you
all to finish this poll.
Still, some of you
are getting it wrong.
OK.
So please answer it quick.
And then we're going to end.
Are we all done?
Get your participation
points here.
Three seconds.
OK, ending.
OK, doesn't matter.
So here, we ran over.
Sorry about that.
Quick review.
This is what we
didn't quite finish.
This is part 5.
But we'll finish that next time.
OK, when showing
PATH is NL complete,
we also need to list the nodes
for constructing the graph.
The slides only mention--
yeah, I kind of skipped that.
But yeah, you can just
write down all the nodes.
Again, but that's also going
to just take log space,
as you observed.
Yeah, technically, when
you're writing down a graph,
you write down a
list of the nodes,
and you write down
a list of the edges.
I kind of skipped
writing down the nodes.
But yeah, it's the same--
doesn't matter.
So I'm going to say
goodbye to you all.
Thank you.